- On this episode, I invite the interns.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this episode 130 of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
It's a gloomy Tuesday
here in New York City,
like we've had pretty
good weather this summer.
Like, I was caught off guard
when I left my building,
it was like pouring, I was like,
didn't even look at the weather
and I've been taking it for granted.
I was reminded this is
not San Diego this morning
so no taking for granted,
I will look at my weather
app tomorrow morning.
Matt is coming with my
phone, that excites me.
I'm really excited to be back on the show.
This is a very special episode.
This is the intern episode.
Three interns are gonna sit with me today
who have spent their
summer at VaynerMedia
and ask me a question.
I'm excited about that.
India is here.
Sid the intern is here as well.
Sid you should actually ask a question,
let's do four, you're in now.
So four interns will ask me a question.
What else is going on?
I'm starting to get serious
about my Snapchat game.
I tested it a little bit yesterday,
I thought it was pretty good.
I see some head-shaking, so that's good.
I'm excited about what I was doing there.
Which will be scary because I think people
will now get a real sense
of how much traveling
I actually do if I document through there.
So it excites me, what else?
The WineDeals Instagram
account has been very much
in right hook zone.
Emily, thank you for
following the account.
Emily, you know what, you may be
also able to ask a question.
I do need five questions so
we might as well just do that.
Emily is not an intern
but she'll explain who she is
when she gets on the show.
So, I don't even like, India,
what are you, just gonna hang?
And just like watch?
- Pretty much, yeah.
A little day off.
- All right, interns,
and then I'm not even
gonna do this with you, all right.
Interns, let's get into the show.
Cool, who wants to come up first?
- [Voiceover] How about...
- I'm in.
Gotta kick off with the Belichik fan.
- Yes, absolutely.
I'm excited, are you
ready for this season?
You concerned about all the injuries?
- I'm a little worried.
- Yeah, I'm not happy.
Tell the Vayner Nation who you are.
- What's up, Vayner Nation?
I'm Russell.
I am a die hard Jet fan much like Gary.
I go to USC.
What else about me?
This is good.
- That's what, yeah.
Yeah, I'm gonna work.
Listen, anything you can
do to show how great I am
on camera is always good.
Good way to kick off, way
to kiss up to the boss.
All right, so, good summer?
- Yeah, great summer, I
absolutely love it here.
- This is your last week?
- Yeah, we're done, it's crazy.
- When are you back to school?
- I go back on Saturday.
- Excited?
- So, we're back, oh, pumped.
It's a very big year, that football team
is actually gonna be good, so, you know.
- I'm actually optimistic.
- Are you?
- Yeah, I need to watch them play
a couple pre-season games,
there's a couple key things
I'm looking for on the offensive line,
and at the linebacker position,
but I think I could be
optimistic, we'll see.
- Well, Gino, but anyway.
We're diving into the question.
Has there ever been a point for you where
you've kind of been
overwhelmed with options
for where you wanted to go,
kind of, in your career,
and life and what was
the thought process,
and the decision making
process you went through
when you ultimately made a decision?
- I think it's happened
more, unlike what I think
you're going with your
question as you're younger,
you may be in school,
there's a lot of options.
You know, to me, I was
set at your age, right?
I was, I mean, I barely went to college,
I was like, I that badly wanted to go
into the family business and do my thing.
Where I started having
these things happen really
is more of like the last
five to seven year phenomenon
where I'm crippled by business options.
Do I want to be a venture capitalist,
do I want to start companies,
do I want to do more econ,
do I want to do TV shows?
Like, I've had a lot
of options in the last
five to seven years, and I think for me,
you know, what I like to do
is run on two parallel paths.
So, here's my piece of advice.
One, I'm constantly debating them, right?
I mean, you just have
to, you're a human being,
you're thinking about your options.
But I'm always doing something.
I think the thing that bothers me
is that people are
crippled by their options,
and then actually aren't
doing anything in parallel,
they're lollygagging while they decide,
and to me, whatever you're deciding,
given that these should
all be loaded questions,
whatever is in your option
point, you need to be doing.
Right, you need to be executing.
So, if there's three
or four tangible things
going on in your mind,
you need to make sure
your internships, your
free time, you know,
whatever you can do to let you taste them
and get context around them
is what really matters.
- Sweet.
- That's it, good.
- Awesome.
- I thought there was
gonna be a follow up.
- Oh, in terms of that, I mean,
that makes a lot of sense, just...
- It's about execution, right?
Like, to me, what I was
doing was I showed up
on TV a lot, I did angel investing,
I ran VaynerMedia, like, I
was doing all these things.
I think people are
confused that you could be
doing a lot of things
at once if you're able
to stretch that rubber band.
- But how much of it
would you say is like,
following your passion
versus kind of like,
trying new things, and
experimenting, and seeing...
- I would never try anything
that I'm not excited about.
Like, to me, when I hear you
say following your passion,
literally, what I heard is,
how much is it about oxygen?
Like, to me, that's the only thing.
Like, everything I just
mentioned are all things
that I want to do.
Like, do you know how
many people have asked me
to go into politics?
- I'd vote for you.
- So, but I don't want to do that.
And so, I've never pondered that.
Right?
And so, you know, to me, you know,
teaching is interesting.
I think I'm a modern teacher,
I like it, I love this,
but I don't wanna do
it, I don't wanna do it
in the way that USC actually wants me
to teach a course.
The guy that I came, and did that course,
where he's like, look,
we'll set it all up for you,
you can be a professor.
And there was a part of me
like, my mom would really
get a kick out of that,
but other than that,
I'm like, I don't wanna do that.
And so, all of it has to do with passion,
but you can have passion about a lot
of different things.
So, to me, if you're
contemplating anything
that's practical or money
based, get the hell out.
Like, oh, I can go into
finance and make more money.
That's, like, I think
that is a terrible idea.
Cool.
- Thanks, man.
- Real pleasure.
Next!
Hey.
- Hello.
- How are you?
- Good.
How are you?
- Tell the Vayner Nation who you are.
- His, I'm Sabina, the
core insights intern,
and I'm also a co-founder of Linute.
- I love the plug.
DRock, give her a little pop up.
All right.
Really, you came prepared.
Listen, I love the, listen, I promise you,
they're gonna love the hustle.
All right.
- Okay, so, my question is,
hypothetically speaking,
you meet a co-founder of a start-up.
What can I, or, that person do?
- Oh, this is a hypothetical question.
- To convince you to meet their team.
For five minutes.
A minute.
- Well, you, that, I would be
more than happy to do for you.
In general, it's just a
little bit of serendipity.
I get asked all the time,
I get pounded all the time,
like, living my life, like,
going to school functions
with my wife, or parties, or
just living life right now,
I am fully in, I get pitched mode.
Right, which is, for me, super flattering.
I'm humbled that I've hit a status where
that's what people want from me, and so,
my money or my time, or
attention, or points of view,
all of it is still
humbling and interesting.
So, you know, for you, that's a done deal
we'll schedule that.
For everybody else who's
watching, they've all tried.
I've got, there's people
who are watching right now
who have emailed me 90
times, who have hit me up
on social media 90
times, and who will never
get that at bat.
It's literally just the
serendipity of it all.
There's other people on their first email,
or their first tweet, or
their first, you know, thing,
get that at bat.
I have so much volume
that I have no real way
to truly have a system.
My Vayner/RSE has a structure
where you can definitely
go through that process and
can eventually get to me,
but you gotta go through
the Phils, and the Shauns,
and the Kevins, and the
Ryans, and the Chloes.
So, you know, that's
it, that's the answer.
I think one of the really
smart, strategic ways,
hypothetically, is to
actually get an internship
at VaynerMedia, put...
- Slowly.
- Put in good work.
Finagle your way into
the #AskGaryVee Show,
where, on the spot, in
front of the VaynerNation,
you can ask the question,
which then compels me
to actually do it.
That would be something
that I would consider.
- That sounds like a very smart person.
I think you should meet them.
I'm just kidding.
- Hit up Matt, let's do it.
- Okay, hi dad.
- Oh, dad, I love it.
- [India] Sid, you go.
- Sid, my intern.
My guy.
Sid, tell, they know you a little bit,
but give 'em the official.
- Hi, VaynerNation, I am
Sid, I've been working
with Team Gary for the last 10 months.
I'm a graduate student at Babson,
and my question is a little
bit around you because like,
how in depth I've seen you working, and,
I've seen you go all
in when you were like,
doing something, but
then we also, as a team,
have seen that you step
back and see things
in a wider perspective and
then you change direction,
come up with creative ideas.
So, how do you decide when it's like,
a moment to just step back and reconsider?
- That's an interesting question.
You know, it's funny, you know,
I always say to candidates
when I meet with them,
meeting with a lot of senior people
who are gonna run a
lot of departments here
at Vayner in the future, and I say, look,
you know me in the outside, and you think
that I'm gonna micro manage a ton.
What's weird is I'm very the other way.
Like, I actually have a lot of, you know,
it's, you know, I always
wanna ask, you know,
I almost completely wanna reverse this
to the ask Sid show because I'm curious
how you quantify for, to me,
this is a very hard answer for me
because it's just innate, right?
Like, it's just to how
I, I don't even know.
Meaning, yeah, I mean, I feel when I have
to go deep, I feel like
when I have to go wide,
I'm reacting to what feels intuitive to me
at the moment, I'm quantifying the people
that are involved in the situation.
The market, it's, you know,
it's kind of like a feeling
to understand what to do at that moment.
What I think happens is when I taste it,
I talk about, I use the analogy of like,
blood in the water,
shark mentality, right?
When I taste it, then I
wanna go all in, right?
Like, then I'm like, let's go, right?
And so, but I don't know how to quantify
what it takes for me to taste it.
I feel like it's a combination
of me and my partner
in crime, team, or individual
is now at a crescendo
to like, to be able to really attack it,
and I can like, really
go in, and there's like,
a cadence between the
two of us that allows us
to deliver on it.
You know, Sid, I think
that's a shit answer,
and I apologize.
There's some answers that
are just tough to, you know,
like, it's just, how do
you describe the feeling,
but I do believe this
is the essence of what,
why I always believe that entrepreneurship
and being a business man
or woman is a talent.
This question is the same
question of like, you know,
like, how do you know
when to hit the high note?
Like, when do you know it's game time,
and you've gotta shoot,
and stop passing the ball?
Like, you know, when do you know like,
how to like, like, being
a great surgeon, like,
where do you like, it's
just the feel and the rhythm
of the game, and as a business
person, I've said this,
Emily, you might have heard this, like,
some of you guys might have heard this,
I've been saying to a couple
people here and there,
that the company feels
more manageable to me.
Like, right now, I feel more in control
of four offices and 550 people than I did
when we were at 200.
It's just, it's the rhythm of it.
And so, that's why I know it's a talent.
There's nothing I was taught,
there's no blue print,
it's just being one with the business.
So weird.
But it's what it is, it's
like, it just, I understand it.
And you know what's funny?
I don't think it's right or wrong,
I think what you're observing, and I know
you've been very observant, which is why
it was a fun question to hear from you,
it's right for me.
You know what I mean?
It's not the right thing
that you need to go
and deploy against you, it's
not right for your start up,
it's what's right for me, and what's,
the one thing that I do love about myself,
and this is just flat out, I don't let,
nobody has any equity from
my parents, to my brother,
to my most trusted
employees, nobody has impact,
or can wait, make me
waiver, or dents that belief
in me, and it, and that thing.
An that unwavering has brought me enormous
amounts of value.
It's like, just like, just the
strongest thing in my world.
Like, me and the business
at hand, you know,
in harmony without
allowing any other voice
to even have a peep in that direction
has been very, very important to me.
Cool.
All right, let's keep going.
This is a good episode.
Interns.
(laughing)
Bringin' it.
- Hey, Gary.
- How are you , my man?
- Good to see you.
- I like your chest hair.
- Thank you.
- Weirdly attracted to it.
- Appreciate it, appreciate it.
- Tell the nation.
- Hi, Vayner Nation, my name is Michael,
I'm gonna be a senior at
the University of Michigan.
I am a DJ and huge dance music enthusiast.
- Love it.
- So, for the last intern question,
I'm gonna get a little deeper with you.
- Okay.
- So, I wanna ask...
- Was that a dig at Sid?
- No.
- I'm not sure, 'cause
he went pretty deep.
- No, it was good.
We're gonna go on a
different level, though.
- That's good.
I love it.
- So, I wanna know how you define love,
and what that means to you, and
how that personal definition
affects your relationships.
- That's a very good question.
I actually, this one is
actually very easy for me.
It's something that I got to in my mind.
Love is very easy for me.
Love, to me, is actually
shifting your brain
or your feelings into
a place where you value
the other person more than yourself.
Like, the people that I love, I truly,
truly, in general, I'm a
pretty empathetic, like,
you know, really care
about the other person's
point of view, and how do I bring value,
but that whole 51 49
thing that I talk about
from a business standpoint, which,
a lot of you know what I'm referring to,
but people that are
watching for the first time,
or others that don't know is,
hey, give 51% of the value
in the relationship, you'll always win.
When it comes to the people that I love,
I'm very comfortable in being at 100 zero.
When I make that shift, when
I fell in love with Lizzie,
to my kids, my parents, my siblings,
Brandon, my best friend
who runs Wine Library,
those core couple of people
that I would say I love,
I'm very comfortable in providing
the entire value in the relationship.
That, it's crazy, the more I love you,
and this has actually been something
that I've struggled with in my life,
but it is absolutely how I define love.
The more I love you down the chain
is the more that I, is the level of which
I want less from you.
So, like, the people I love the most,
I literally don't want anything from.
I wanna provide so much
disproportionate value,
I want to never make myself a burden
or something they think
they need to deliver on,
and I want it to be, I wanna
be the first person they call,
and the person that they most rely on,
and trust in the world.
And as my love goes down, that
goes down to just maybe even.
That's how I define it.
- I like it.
- Cool, man.
Thanks.
Thanks for your summer.
M.
- [Voiceover] Hi.
- Hey.
- How are you?
- I'm well.
- It's so rainy, you've
got a lot of energy though.
- Whoa.
Let me see your shoe.
Look at this thing.
- Oh, oh.
- This is what we do on the show.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, this is how we do it.
- It's rainy, and so like,
I like a pop of color.
All right, here we go.
So.
- [Voiceover] Will you
take off yours?
- Yeah, okay.
- Yeah, a little side by side style issue.
Yeah.
- We match there.
- Yeah.
I've always got an element, yeah.
- Tell Vayner Nation.
- Hi, I'm Emily, I work on VaynerMedia
communications team, I am
very excited to be there,
it's some interesting
stuff that we're doing,
and I led the internship
program this summer,
so all of these characters
that are in here
somehow had to interact
with me to get in the door.
It's been amazing, I think
it's awesome this year
that we had interns in
different departments.
So, not just all social media interns,
we had people in studio
doing copyrighting,
doing interesting things
like team fury, so,
it's been an awesome experience.
- Cool.
So, my question is kind
of around career growth.
- Yes.
- And how you map that.
I heard you say recently
that for your 30th birthday,
you freaked out and
started Wine Library TV.
- I did.
- And I thought that was interesting thing
to map back, was that the
start of a hockey stick
that you kinda went on?
I know you talk about turning 40,
and how that's very exciting.
- Couple months away.
Exciting.
A la, I might just disappear.
- I'm excited, yeah.
How do you see, sort of
like, milestones like that,
like, an age or something like that,
and sort of like, career,
and comparing yourself
to sort of like, where you should be or...
- I don't know if I'll
ever have anything like 30
because 30 was a real kind
of interesting moment for me
because I really, really felt
for the first time in my life,
on my 30th birthday, that I
would not buy the New York Jets,
or that my, you know, and I think, look,
this is a good time to
talk about it if like,
if it's confusing to
anybody, I'd be very okay
if I don't buy the New York Jets.
I want to buy the New York Jets,
but more importantly, I want the process
of buying the New York
Jets, and what hit me was
my behavior wasn't
acting towards a process
of buying the New York Jets.
That I was starting to become complacent,
which was very weird for me,
and it scared me a little bit.
Like, I had made it, right?
And by everybody else's definition,
and I allowed, in a
world where I very much,
we talked about it in Sid's question,
live in my little world, for some reason,
you know, obviously I got married at,
the day before my 29th birthday, so Lizzie
was new in my life, like,
whatever had happened
in those two, or three, or
four years from 26 to 30,
it was the most complacent
version of myself.
I mean, I am a, dramatically,
more of a hustler today
than I was at 26, which is
tough because I have children
and a marriage, and
I'm like, damn, I mean,
this would have been a
much, I'd much rather
have worked it out, which
is why I push that objective
so much in people's 20s,
that's when you don't
go for the cash, that's
when you sleep on the floor.
Right?
Like, with 19 people, and like, this room.
Like, Jerome Jarre slept at VaynerMedia.
Right, like, he hustled,
and now he makes millions
of dollars being Jerome
Jarre, freakin' slept here.
Like, I know what it takes, and I, so,
anyway, I don't know why
I'm going left field,
birthdays are interesting.
You've had some big birthdays recently.
Birthdays are interesting for me.
I'm definitely freaking
out about my 40th birthday.
Like, because what's happening
in my brain right now
is like, 40 to 50 is the
foundational decade of like,
you know, like, if I don't
really crush that decade,
and there's a part of
me that laughs at me,
because then I'm like, hm.
Then I'm gonna come to 50
and be like, all right,
50 or 60 is, like, this is
where you really go to moguls.
Like, I know my, I'm
self aware enough to know
that's how I'm driven.
I have this equal push
to like massive ambition
and equal understanding
of myself knowing that
the goals that, you know, it's funny,
I can't wait to be a
public figure in my 60s,
70s, and 80s, and talk about,
there's a weird part of me,
and it's an emerging weird part that says,
wow, I can make a bigger
impact on the world
if I don't buy the Jets
because I could talk about,
you know, the satisfaction
that I have in that
I gave it my all, and I, you
know, there's serendipity,
and there's other variables,
or that, you know,
this, you know, I'm a weird
dude, this tragic event
happened, and I adjusted my
priorities for, this incredible
thing happened, let's look
at the bright side, and I,
you know, my son was a whiz
kid violinist, and I decided
to deploy against that.
You know, so, I think that
the way I think about it is
for me, birthdays are weird, I,
definitely milestone birthdays.
30 and, 40 is ripping me right now,
and like, 30 did, and so 50 will, and so,
and I don't know if I'm
forcing that narrative or not,
but they're real, but I think
that they definitely make me
think about things and readjust, like,
I'm sure that, it's a
cliche thing that I'm sure
happens to everybody, but
I didn't have them at 18,
or 21, or 25, it started at 30 for me.
And probably speaks to
what I'm ambitious about.
I wasn't as much worried
about my childhood,
or things that of that nature.
My career has been the beacon of my life
outside of my family, and that's what,
I don't associate myself
with, you know, like,
being a party dude, or
like, getting the most
out of my 20s, it was
more career oriented.
And so, I think it's
different for everybody.
And I think, you know, it also speaks to,
you know, these big birthdays are also
a tremendously important time
to reflect around family and health.
Obviously, I took care of my health,
and in spending a
disproportionate amount of time
on my family hacking, as happy as I am
with the extremism of
weekends and vacation time,
I'm starting to bubble
up some other thoughts.
And so, I think, you know, I
think it's fun being a human,
like, it's fun to hang
out with the interns here
who are like, starting to
go to that next chapter
where like, the game they've
played their entire lives
of school infrastructure's gonna go away,
and they go into a different game.
And that's interesting to watch,
and that's interesting that my parents
are interesting to watch to me.
You know, there was
something I read that said,
you know, when you save
money your whole life,
you don't know how to spend it.
So, I'm watching my
parents struggle to relax
and enjoy this next
chapter of their lives.
And so, like, I'm very
observant as a business person
around psychology, but
also as like, a human,
I'm interested in how people roll,
and I think the best thing
I can say is, you know,
go with what feels right.
Attach yourself to a couple
principles that matter the most,
and let the cards play out as they will.
- Thanks.
- Cool.
Deep, deep.
(laughing)
I didn't know the intern episode
was gonna get so deep.
I guess that's it, good.
nice and kind of tight, I mean,
my answers were pretty long, here you go.
Hope you enjoyed that show, I really did,
I really enjoyed it.
It was weird not to interact with you
a whole bunch, India, I felt kinda...
- I'm sad.
- Yeah, I'm a little sad myself.
But don't worry.
Now that the golden era has ended,
we'll get back to like, engaging on 131.
Question of the day.
Tell me a story about your
most impactful birthday,
you know, tell me about your
year that made you think,
or you did something.
It's a good opportunity for the community
to get to know each other more.
Obviously, there's a
post I posted on Facebook
over the weekend that allowed you guys
to kind of like, talk about yourselves,
and biz dev, and boy,
did you take me up on it.
And it was great to see
the community interact
with each other.
I think for Facebook and YouTube comments,
lurkers, this would be a
tremendous time to come out
and tell us a story
about you, the birthday,
the signature birthday,
so far in your life,
and a little story around it.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Why don't you guys come
over here next to me
and then I'll do the
intro with you guys in it.
Actually, you know what?
Why don't you guys stand?
And so, like, make the shot like, of them,
and then go up to them.
It would be funny.
- [DRock] All right, director.
- That's good, right?
I'm a director now.
(hip hop music)